SUNNI YUEN: Hello,
I'm Sunni Yuen.
I'm a member of Google's
legal department here.
And today we are hosting Helen
Wan, associate general counsel
from Time Inc. And
Helen is here to talk
about her new book called
"The Partner Track."
So Helen, if you could give us
a quick summary of your book
is about.
HELEN WAN: Sure.
So "The Partner
Track" is a novel.
It's decidedly fiction.
It follows the journey of a
young Chinese American woman
who is climbing the corporate
ladder in corporate America.
It's set at a large law
firm and it basically
talks about the ways in which
being an outsider, in all
the things that word
might mean, can impact
the journey of talented
young person on their way
up the corporate ladder.
SUNNI YUEN: So are law
firm corporate ladders
different than corporate
corporate ladders?
You've worked at
both, a law firm
and also obviously at Time Inc?
HELEN WAN: Right.
So I'm associate general
counsel at the Time Inc.
division of Time Warner.
And so having worked now
both as an in-house lawyer
and also as a law
firm attorney, I
do think the two are quite
culturally different.
Just like any corporate
culture is different.
Like, for example,
you guys at Google,
you must know within
the corporate community
Google is sort of
like the Disneyland
of the corporate world.
The happiest place
on earth, you know.
And I come here and I see
people are on scooters.
So obviously every
corporate culture is unique.
And I think one of the
messages of my book,
what I was hoping to
convey, is that it's
so important to land there and
right away learn, figure out
the corporate culture,
and then identify
your own place within
it in a way that
can feel authentic and
comfortable to yourself.
SUNNI YUEN: And this is
something your protagonist--
her name is Ingrid Yung, and
she's been described variously
throughout the book as
brainy but beautiful,
or beautiful but brainy.
HELEN WAN: Described
by some reviewers.
SUNNI YUEN: By reviewers or
other characters in your book.
She's also been described
as a sour-faced fraulein,
based on her name alone.
HELEN WAN: Yes, by
clients in the book.
SUNNI YUEN: How much of
yourself is in this protagonist?
HELEN WAN: I always get
asked this question.
One of the first questions
I get asked at book events
is how much of the book
is autobiographical.
And the answer to that is I
am an Asian American female
lawyer.
My first job fresh
out of law school,
as a 25-year-old
out of law school
was indeed as an M&A associate
at a large corporate law firm.
The firm where I happened
to work was Paul Weiss.
But that's sort of where the
similarities in terms of what
happens to her career-wise stop
because unlike my protagonist,
I did not stay at the law firm.
I actually left after
just under two years
to go to an
entertainment law firm.
And then from there I lateraled
in-house to Time Warner.
So my own career path is quite
different than Ingrid's, but I
tried very hard to do the
research necessary to make
that big law culture as
realistic as possible.
SUNNI YUEN: And for those
of you who might not
have had a chance to
read Helen's book yet,
Ingrid Yung is the protagonist.
She has quite a
resume that I think
we at Google would be
very impressed with.
Played varsity soccer
three semesters
at Yale, valedictorian,
voted most likely to succeed,
Phi Beta Kappa, Law Review.
And she is certainly
someone who's
not afraid to confront anyone
who challenges or raises
stereotypes about herself.
Would you say that's something
that you feel very personal
about, the ability to
confront stereotyping?
HELEN WAN: I do.
And one thing that I
tried to show in the book
is how when a person in
works in corporate America
they often, I think,
have one-- it's
like a split personality a bit.
The person you are
at work, or feel
that you need to be at
work, and the person
that you are outside of work.
And there's one
scene, I think one
that you might be
alluding to, where
Ingrid reacts to a challenging
offensive situation in a way
that she absolutely
does not allow herself
when she is in the kind
of public eye at work.
SUNNI YUEN: Work life
balance, literally, right?
And it's severed right here.
HELEN WAN: Exactly.
SUNNI YUEN: Could you share
something from your book
just so we could get to
know Ingrid a little?
HELEN WAN: Sure.
So we were discussing it
might be a nice way to,
before we launch into
our conversation-- I
do hope it'll be an interactive
conversation-- that we could
frame it by my just reading
a couple of quick snippets
from the book.
So actually let me just start
by asking how many people here
in the audience
have ever attended
a company outing, like
a firm's summer outing?
OK, it's practically everyone.
And I suspect that a
Google summer outing
might look quite different
than a corporate law firm
summer outing, obviously.
SUNNI YUEN: White shoe law firm.
HELEN WAN: Yeah, within
a white shoe law firm.
But all you need to
know to place this scene
is that it takes
place at the summer
outing of the fictitious law
firm of Parsons, Valentine,
and Hunt.
And it's taking place at
the Oak Hollow Country Club
in Westchester.
The scene by the pool
was in full swing
by the time I got down there.
No one was swimming, but a line
had already formed at the bar.
Coolers packed with
ice, Perrier, Gatorade,
and bottled beer were positioned
at convenient intervals
across the spotless pool deck.
I did what I always did.
Got a club soda
with a wedge of lime
and then stretched out on a
green and white striped lounge
chair.
Crossing my ankles demurely,
pasting a smile onto my face,
and trying to look like I
was having a fantastic time.
The sun reflected off
the glittering surface
of the pool like tiny gemstones.
It felt good on my
face and shoulders
and I leaned back and closed
my eyes, relaxing a little.
Before long I heard
two loud splashes
and some high-pitched giggles.
I opened my eyes.
It was the same group of
chatty summer associates
I had seen on the bus.
Two of the guys had
already cannonballed
into the deep end of the pool
while a third, Steinberg, was
making a beeline
for the open bar.
I put my sunglasses
back on so I could
watch a little more carefully.
I was curious and more
than a little nostalgic.
There had been 95 of
us in my entering class
when we'd first started
out, and over a third of us
had been women.
But now, eight years later,
in corporate it was just me,
Murph, Hunter, and
Tyler left standing.
I was still friends
with a lot of the women
who had left the
firm over the years,
and I knew that they
all rooted for me.
Every Christmas I received
an enthusiastic chorus
of messages.
Keep up the good fight.
Looking forward to
toasting the firm's
first female corporate partner.
These messages
typically came scrawled
on the back of a
holiday photo card
featuring some impossibly cute
two-year-old in a reindeer
costume.
As I watched this latest
crop of summer associates
shrieking and splashing
each other in the pool,
I thought about how much I
missed that easy camaraderie.
That freedom you felt when
you were nowhere near up
for partner.
The blissful safety in numbers.
It was so much harder to blend
in when there was only one
of you.
The one called
Steinberg was back now
with a large tropical
drink served in a hollowed
out pineapple.
Hey, he yelled to
one of the girls.
Why aren't you in the pool yet?
This particular girl-- the
prettiest girl in the group--
was a tall willowy blonde with
high cheekbones, fair skin,
and a faint spray of freckles
across the bridge of her nose.
Her hair was swept back
into an unfussy French twist
and secured with a single,
tiny, tortoiseshell pin.
She was wearing a
chic black cover up
and the white spaghetti
straps of a swimsuit top
were visibly knotted
together behind her neck.
I knew her name,
Cameron Alexander,
because Murph and Hunter had
pointed her out many times
in the summer
associate directory.
Also known among the male
attorneys as the menu.
Cameron had been to Exeter
and was a double Harvard,
both college and law school.
And, according to her firm
bio, did some modeling
in her spare time.
Runway, not catalog.
Rumor had it she was
also dating a client,
the manager of an exclusive
hedge fund that we represented.
Come on, Cameron, said
the one called Steinberg.
You said you'd be going in.
I don't see anyone stopping
you from swimming, Jason,
Cameron Alexander said with
an expert task of her head.
Why does it always have to be
follow the leader with you?
This seemed to shut
Steinberg up for a moment,
and the other men in
his group snickered.
Hey Ingrid, mind if I join you?
I looked up.
It was Tim Hollister, a
youngish corporate partner
from our Emerging Markets group.
A glint came off his
Clark Kent glasses
where the sunlight
caught them just so.
Of course not, I
said, pull up a chair.
I liked Tim Hollister.
He had been in the associate
class three years above me
and seemed a little
surprised to have woken up
one day to discover himself
occupying a huge corner office.
Even after he had made
partner at the firm,
Tim still managed to
seem like one of us.
He was the type of guy who
rarely asked associates
to work on weekends if he
wasn't also coming in himself.
Tim swung the nearest deck chair
around, parked it next to mine,
and opened the bottled
water he was holding.
Oh, no tropical
slushy today, Tim?
I asked, inclining my
head towards Steinberg
and the hollowed out pineapple.
Tim looked over and grinned.
Wow it's only 10:50.
I try to wait until
at least noon.
Then he looked at me and
said, because this is always
such a long day, you know?
I nodded and felt
grateful to Tim Hollister
for having said this out loud.
We sat in comfortable
silence for a moment.
I slid my huge Audrey
Hepburn-style sunglasses back
onto my face and studied
Tim Hollister in profile.
Rumor had it that
Tim actually had
a Ph.D. In political theory
in addition to his law degree,
which made him seem
rather worthy of note
to lots of women at the firm.
As I was busy thinking all
this, he opened his mouth
and said to me, So
Ingrid, the buzz
is that you've impressed the
hell out of the SunCorp CEO.
I nearly fell out of my chair.
Tim Hollister and I did
not know each other well.
The fact that this had made
its way to him was news.
I'm surprised you heard about
that, Tim, but thanks, I said.
Are you kidding?
Tim looked genuinely
happy for me.
There are no secrets around
this place, believe me.
Marty Adler's been crowing
about you all week.
And I just wanted to say I
think it's really well deserved.
I felt my face
flush with pleasure.
I tried to think of something
both witty and sincere
to say back.
But Tim had already
turned away from me
and was looking toward the exit.
Gavin Dunlop, another
young M&A partner,
was gesturing impatiently at
him, pointing at his watch
and making exaggerated swinging
motions with both arms.
Tim stood.
I gotta run.
I have an 11 o'clock tee time.
See you, and thanks.
I really appreciate
what you said.
Any time.
Tim jogged over toward
Gavin and the two of them
headed up the grassy slope
toward the clubhouse.
I took in a long, deep breath
and stretched out my arms
and legs as far as
they would reach,
feeling the pleasant
pull in each muscle.
The sheer joy of being young
and appreciated and good
at what you did.
I draped one arm lazily above
my head and closed my eyes,
luxuriating in the
warmth of the sun
and in Tim Hollister's words.
I think it's really
well deserved.
My eyes were still closed
when suddenly I thought,
it's really quiet.
It's too quiet.
A reverent hush had
fallen over the pool deck
and when I opened
my eyes I saw why.
Cameron Alexander had now
peeled off her cover-up
and was sauntering toward
the shallow end of the pool
wearing only white
string bikini.
She moved with an
unhurried grace,
as if she were aware
of so many eyes on her
and really didn't mind.
Steinberg was obediently
loping along behind her,
still clasping his ridiculous
pineapple beverage.
He looked like a five-year-old
on Christmas morning.
For women lawyers
at a firm outing,
the swimsuit question
presents a conundrum.
Just what should a
young career woman
wear to what was
essentially a pool
party thrown by one's employer?
On the one hand,
let's be honest.
Companies value good looks and
sex appeal as much as anyone.
So if you are an
attractive young woman,
you didn't exactly
want to be the class
prude huddled
poolside in a parka.
On the other hand,
showing too much skin
wasn't a good idea either.
Especially not if
you ever expected
to be taken seriously again,
and especially not the year you
were up for partner.
Unflustered, Cameron
Alexander stood alone
at the water's edge.
She raised one perfect
pilates-toned leg
and dipped a pointed
toe into the water.
It's still pretty
cold, she announced,
loud enough for
everyone to hear.
I think I'll wait a bit.
Steinberg didn't seem
disappointed to hear this,
as his objective had
already been achieved.
Fine with me, he said, shaking
his empty pineapple drink
at her.
I'm out.
Let's go get another drink.
Cameron shrugged
and together they
walked to the back
of the drinks line,
where they were quickly joined
by two male partners who
were suddenly very
interested in striking up
a conversation with
the summer associates.
Before long, Cameron and
Steinberg's own group
of friends joined them
too, forming a large gaggle
in front of the open bar.
All of the summers
were trying to schmooze
all of the partners,
but none succeeded
like Cameron Alexander.
She looked almost queenly,
wearing a beneficent smile
and occasionally throwing
her head back with laughter
as if it were the most
natural thing in the world
to be standing around barefoot
with the corporate tax
partners chatting animatedly
about the latest summer
action flick.
All the while wearing
a white string bikini
and gesturing with your
mojito for emphasis.
I was, if I'm being
honest, jealous.
Of course I was.
But not actually
of the way Cameron
looked in a white string bikini.
Instead, I was jealous
of her confidence
and her utter
unselfconsciousness.
What must be like,
I marveled, to go
through life so utterly unwary?
So wholly certain of
your belonging to a place
that it was never
necessary to consider
how your next move
might be perceived?
Making partner at Parsons,
Valentine, and Hunt
felt like a big final exam
to which a select few held
the answer key, while the rest
of us schmucks had to study.
So that is one scene that
illustrates Ingrid's frequent,
but not constant, views
of life in the workplace
as an outsider looking in.
But just as frequently
she sometimes
experiences her corporate
career from the point
of view of an
insider looking out.
Because she is
someone who has been
extremely successful
in her career.
She has perfected the
art of passing and she
as blended basically seamlessly
into the corporate culture.
Until something happens
in the plot of the story
where all of a sudden her
difference and her status as
not only a woman, but also a
woman of color in particular,
is suddenly thrown
into sharp relief.
So it's not a plot spoiler
to say that at one point
her company engages a
diversity consultant.
So they have to engage this
outside diversity and inclusion
corporate consultant to come in.
And because Ingrid is one of
the very, very few senior level
women, and also she
is a woman of color,
she is asked to subject
yourself to an interview
with this diversity consultant.
And this is their first meeting.
Now you've obviously been very
successful in your career here
and that's terrific.
But could I invite
you to speculate
on why there's only one of
you who has made it this far?
That is to say, why
there aren't more women
of color up for partnership.
While I tried to think
of a diplomatic response,
Dr. Rossi held up an
Excel spreadsheet.
I see that in your
entering class
there was another
Asian American woman,
but she quit within the
first year and a half.
And I'm curious to hear
your thoughts about this.
Why do you feel the company
was unable to retain her?
I remembered this woman,
Zhang Liu, very clearly.
For the first few months after
our new associate orientation
a lot of people had had
trouble telling us apart,
even though we
looked nothing alike.
Zhang wore her hair
short with bangs,
while mine was long and layered.
Zhang also stood a
head taller than me,
yet a year later we still got
each other's interoffice mail.
Zhang Liu was from Beijing
and had come to the States
at the age of 18 to attend MIT.
She had aced the bar exam and
every other standardized test
known to civilization,
Zhang was brilliant,
but she spoke English
that was technically
correct, yet strongly accented.
Her blunt cut hair
sometimes looked
like it needed
shampooing, and she
wore shapeless,
ill-fitting suits that
obscured what was actually
really decent figure.
She was extremely shy and never
joined in when a group of us
went out to grab lunch
or drinks after work.
And on the rare occasions when
she did accept our invitation
to come out, Zhang
would hover silently
on the outer fringes of our
group nursing single 7 Up
while the rest of us tossed
back martinis and traded
dirty jokes and gossip.
And when she did speak her
voice was so soft and low
it barely rose above a whisper.
Once at a department
meeting I had
seen Marty Adler lose
his patience and snap,
speak up, Zhang, for God's sake.
I had never Marty Adler speak
to another associate like that
either before or since,
and it had stuck with me.
Another time Harold
Rubenstein had
praised Zhang for an excellent
research memo she had prepared.
This was extremely
well done, Zhang,
he said in front of all of us.
Great job.
But Zhang had blushed
and stammered something
in protest about how it had
really been a team effort
and that truly two
summer associates had
done most of the work.
She just wasn't getting it.
Everyone knew that on
the rare occasion when
a partner publicly
praised your work,
the only right
answer was thank you.
About a year after we started,
Zhang ventured to my office
late one night.
She knocked
tentatively on my door
and I looked up startled from
the stack of corporate minutes
I'd been reviewing
and marking up.
Apropos of nothing,
Zhang Liu asked me
if I knew how to speak Chinese.
No, I lied.
I knew how much courage this
must have taken on her part,
and I knew just how much
it must have cost her.
Yet, to my own
embarrassment, I could not
summon the courage in
myself to do the kind thing.
It had only did my own first
year, my position at the firm
was not yet so
secure that I thought
that I could afford to be
associated with Zhang Liu
any more than I already was.
I was terrified
she'd drag me down.
I was passing and she was not.
Zhang stuck it out at Parsons
Valentine a few more months,
collected her bonus,
and then quit.
I had no idea
where she'd landed.
I sighed at Dr. Rossi.
All right, look.
Let's just say that
in my experience,
most white guys are still a
lot more comfortable working
with other guys who look, talk,
and act more or less like them.
Well what about the
various initiatives
of the diversity committee,
prodded Dr. Rossi?
I snorted.
As far as I could tell
until the incident,
the diversity committee at this
firm had been all but defunct.
Their initiatives had
consisted of taking associates
to see The Lion
King on Broadway,
throwing a Margarita happy
hour on Cinco de Mayo,
and serving spring
rolls and dumplings
in the corporate cafeteria
during Asian-Pacific American
Heritage Month.
When we didn't need
fucking dumpling
day in the corporate cafeteria.
What we needed
were decoder rings
for all the unwritten
rules of survival here.
SUNNI YUEN: Thank you, Helen.
That raises a lot of
interesting themes here.
Just in those two passages.
But your protagonist,
Ingrid Yung,
who is a Type A personality,
who can play in same league
as the boys.
And part of that is
using the same slang
and lingo and culture.
Tell us more about
conference room bingo.
HELEN WAN: Conference
room bingo is something
that we actually did play when I
was a young associate at an M&A
large law firm where
the corporate jargon
and the corporate speak
get so ridiculous.
Like kicking the tires or
whatever the phrase of the day.
These catchphrases that
people learn in B-school
and then tote to their jobs.
Or another one of my
favorites was learnings.
Let's write down our
learnings from today.
And low-hanging fruit, like
these kinds of phrases.
And so we would write down a
bunch of these catchphrases,
prior to a meeting,
and we would pick
certain like phrases that paid.
And if one of the ones
that you chose not
uttered during the
course of the meeting,
we played for $20 stakes.
SUNNI YUEN: Now
these phrases that
pay, more on this
sports metaphor side?
HELEN WAN: A lot of sports
metaphors, definitely.
Yeah.
SUNNI YUEN: OK.
HELEN WAN: But not all.
SUNNI YUEN: So I thought
it'd be interesting to have
a small exercise to look at
some Google phrases that pay.
HELEN WAN: Oh yeah, What are
some Google phrases that pay?
SUNNI YUEN: However,
I'm going to you
which our characters would be
the most likely to say that
phrase and why?
HELEN WAN: OK.
SUNNI YUEN: OK.
So the first one is
herd your black sheep.
HELEN WAN: Wait--
SUNNI YUEN: Herd
your black sheep.
HELEN WAN: Who would be the most
likely character to say that?
SUNNI YUEN: Yes.
HELEN WAN: Maybe
Murph, actually.
SUNNI YUEN: So tell us a little
bit more about Murph, and why,
and what this phrase
means to Murph?
HELEN WAN: Well I'm
not even sure what
the phrase means at Google.
Herd your black sheep?
Okay.
SUNNI YUEN: Right.
HELEN WAN: Does that mean
that something went wrong
for that person?
SUNNI YUEN: What I've heard
is being used in the context
for is when you've got a
lot of restless contributors
with unconventional ideas who
are discontent because they can
see alternate ways
of doing things,
but they haven't had
a chance to try it.
Because the established way
is what everybody sticks with.
HELEN WAN: I kind of love that.
I'm going to use that somehow.
But I think I could see Murph
uttering that to someone.
A little bit about the Murph
character in the novel.
Basically every single
character in the novel
is imperfect because
that's real life.
None of us is perfect.
And also to an author
it's just much, much, much
more interesting writing
about imperfect people than
about plastic people.
So Murph is someone
who if you look at him,
one might assume that
he just has it made.
He is the golden
boy of the firm.
Some very, very senior level
rainmakers at the company
have identified him
as the golden boy,
as I said, and have taken
him under their wing.
He just knows how to
play the game perfectly.
He always knows how to
say the right thing.
So Ingrid assumes a lot
of things about him.
And he is just someone who would
know all of the catchphrases
and know how to
employ them perfectly
and insinuates himself socially
very, very well at the firm.
SUNNI YUEN: Great.
So another phrase that pays
from Google, moon shot.
HELEN WAN: What?
SUNNI YUEN: Moon shot.
HELEN WAN: Moon shocked.
AUDIENCE: Shot.
SUNNI YUEN: Shot.
HELEN WAN: Oh, moon shot.
SUNNI YUEN: Yes.
HELEN WAN: OK.
What is that context?
SUNNI YUEN: This is something
that we at Google think about.
Instead of just reaching for the
stars, you reach for the moon.
Big, laudable goals.
HELEN WAN: OK, so that's
kind of like pie in the sky.
SUNNI YUEN: Bigger
than pie in the sky.
Pie in the sky is old.
HELEN WAN: So kind of--
SUNNI YUEN: We're talking
about universe here.
Way up.
HELEN WAN: But is it
in a positive context?
Like achievable.
SUNNI YUEN: It's like
setting your goals.
HELEN WAN: Oh, OK.
SUNNI YUEN: Are you going
to make it achievable
even if it seems like
it's not achievable?
HELEN WAN: I see.
Well Ingrid is
someone who, I think,
sets goals like
that for herself.
And has always done that
throughout her life.
Actually, one of the
additional themes
that are very
important to the book,
aside from just the
theme of advancing
the careers of both
women and women
and people of color in
corporate America generally,
I was also very
interested in writing
about this idea about women's
very complicated relationship
with ambition.
Yes I do think that it's a
very complicated relationship
with ambition.
And that's for a lot of societal
and cultural underpinnings.
And so I guess she is someone
who sets all of these moon
shot type goals for herself.
Not necessarily
because she wants to,
but because she's one
of the very few who can.
And that is a theme
that I think--
SUNNI YUEN: And her moon shot is
to make partner, specifically.
HELEN WAN: Yes.
SUNNI YUEN: OK, and let's do
one last Google phrase to pay.
I'm uncomfortably excited.
Who is the character who's most
likely to say that and why?
HELEN WAN:
Uncomfortably excited.
Maybe Tyler, actually.
SUNNI YUEN: OK.
And tell us about Tyler.
HELEN WAN: So
Tyler is-- actually
he is the other very
senior person of color who
has managed to make it
quite far in the firm.
But Ingrid is his
closest confidante
and friend at the
firm because he's
someone who, unlike Murph--
he's sort of the anti-Murph.
So he, like Ingrid,
being a woman of color,
he also occupies sort
of a double outsider
status within this company.
He is an openly gay African
American male attorney.
And so he and Ingrid have
bonded over this fact.
They're clearly the stars of
the glossy firm recruiting
brochure, et cetera.
Always asked to be
photographed in this context.
But unlike Ingrid, he is
someone who-- basically he
has one foot out the
door and he is not
setting that same goal of
partnership for himself.
In other words, he has
already sort of checked out.
And Ingrid is very, very
nervous about the day
that he's going to leave
because then she'll be left.
He really is her one
confidant and close friend
who she can go to for candid
conversations about some
of these issues.
SUNNI YUEN: It seems
like Tyler's more--
in terms of being photographed
for the firm's diversity
brochures and everything, he's
a very passive participant
in those efforts.
HELEN WAN: That's fair to say.
SUNNI YUEN: And even
Ingrid herself actually
kind of rejects participating
as the diversity initiative
liaison initially.
And it's only after she is
convinced by a senior partner
that it is good for her to
consider to become partner
that she actually assumed
the role reluctantly.
In your opinion, and
based on your experience,
does participating
in diversity efforts
dampen one's ability to blend
in and relate to everybody else?
HELEN WAN: This has
been a question that
has been very frequently
raised a lot of the places
where I've spoken
about the book.
Particularly when the question
comes from other senior level
women who have stayed within
their corporate careers
for a very long time.
And it seems like people fall
into these two different fairly
divided camps.
One set feels not resentful,
but that it is quite a burden.
That they're always
asked to, hey
can you be a mentor
to this person?
Can you come speak
on this panel?
Can you be on this
committee please?
That their point of
view was so on top
of my normal responsibilities
of my already very demanding day
job, I have this extra
investment of time
that the company will
ask me to do just
by virtue of me
being a woman, being
a very senior woman, et cetera.
And not that they
don't want to do it,
it's just that they view it as
an added obligation that is not
necessarily recognized come
compensation time or promotion
time.
But another set, and I would
say the majority actually,
don't share that view.
And say, OK yes it
is another time sink.
It is another added obligation
that perhaps my colleague
Bob in office next
door does not have.
But they also view it as
quite a privilege too.
And they don't have this
view of, well 25 years ago
when I was starting out I didn't
have a mentor, so why should I?
Most people do not have that
view anymore in the audiences
that I have been speaking
to over the last two months.
SUNNI YUEN: What is the critical
difference between being a role
model or a figurehead
for diversity efforts
versus actively
engaging and mentoring?
What really makes
the difference?
HELEN WAN: So in
terms of numbers
and actually moving
the needle, I think.
SUNNI YUEN: Yes.
HELEN WAN: So it's
been interesting.
There has been a lot
of conversation--
I'm sure this will be nothing
new to this audience--
but a lot of conversation
recently about the move
from traditional
mentoring to something
called sponsorship, which is a
very, very crucial difference.
So basically, as
you probably know,
a mentor is someone who can
offer advice and be someone
who can offer candid
feedback, who can take you out
to lunch once in a
while, et cetera,
and talk to you
about your career.
While a sponsor
is someone who is
going to be talking about
you and actually promoting
you and your career potential
to those who are in a position
to do something about it.
And in the various
large companies
where I've been talking about my
book and the large national law
firms and law schools where I
have been talking about my book
recently, there is
tremendous conversation
about this move from
mentorship to sponsorship.
Understanding that
sponsorship is
what is actually going
to move the needle.
And also I'm really encouraged
by a lot of companies
doing very, very smart
things with their employee
professional development
training programs.
Like putting budget toward
very, very smart programs
such as bringing in
consultants to tell you how do
you get the most of your once
a year performance review.
How do you get the most
out of that conversation
so that no one can be
blindsided later down the road
if you are, let's
say, passed over?
And no one ever
gave me the feedback
that I was not seen as
aggressive enough to drive
new business.
When would I have heard that?
You do hear that refrain
over and over, particularly
from female employees.
And companies are
starting to do something
about it, which I
think it's great.
The other thing that
they are starting to do
is instead of having
formalistic-- assigning very
artificial-feeling mentorship
programs like, hey you,
Mary, will mentor John or Sarah.
That is mandated by the company.
I've never really put those
programs tend to work.
Because it's kind of
like dating, right?
You can't assign
somebody a boyfriend.
Life would be so much
easier if you could.
SUNNI YUEN: That's
what [INAUDIBLE].
HELEN WAN: Exactly.
But no, it's got to be organic.
You've got to have
chemistry, and rapport,
and the two people
have to both want
to be in that
mentor-sponsor relationship.
And I think that companies are
kind of getting wise to that
quickly.
SUNNI YUEN: And so just
to address your point
in the theme of
passing or blending in.
So Ingrid is a protagonist
who blends in, or passes in,
with all the other senior
associates, who are all male.
And at the time she's
also keenly aware
that how she dresses
has an impact
in establishing a
presence around men.
She seems to be a fan of Audrey
Hepburn's style in particular.
Right before she meets
with a senior partner
she checks her
mascara, lip gloss,
ties her Audrey Hepburn
style sheath sash.
She wears stiletto
pumps when she
knows that she's meeting
with a client who's maybe
a bit more old
school and expects
women to wear a
skirt and high heels.
And what is that line between
deemphasizing your gender
in your interactions
and behavior,
yet at the same
time playing up what
some might call femininity?
Or also just what
may be expected
for an older kind of
professional code of dress
for women.
How to navigate that.
HELEN WAN: Well I think Ingrid
is someone who just has thought
a lot about, well, what's the
cultural baggage and societal
baggage that each of us brings
into our corporate workplace?
And how can we make the
most of the attributes
that we do have
while still trying
to remain an authentic self?
But she's someone
who has figured out
that, you know what,
I am going to have
to play by the current
rules of this game
because I will get to the goal
quicker than if I try to change
all the rules from
the inside out.
That's just not good.
So that is sort of
why she has observed,
OK if I'm meeting with
that client, that client's
more old school.
He is going to expect to
see that the lawyer is
wearing an actual suit.
And she'll do it.
Rather than someone
who is going to try to,
before she has made
partner herself,
try to break the
rules in advance.
SUNNI YUEN: Do you
think she would actually
break the rules if she
were to become partner?
HELEN WAN: Yes.
I think most people
feel much freer
to break the rules
after they've already
attained C-suite status.
SUNNI YUEN: OK.
Do you think you
would ever see her
in her yoga pants going to work?
HELEN WAN: You
may not see Ingrid
scooting through the halls.
I just think that's
human nature.
Once a comfort level
has been reached
people feel far more free
to be more of the person
that they are outside
of work, and bring
that person to the office.
SUNNI YUEN: So that raises
an interesting point.
What is work identity?
What is personal identity?
And to a certain extent
one informs the other.
You can't really divorce them.
Ingrid's mother has a really
compassionate and interesting
quote where she's talking on
the phone in one of the scenes
to Ingrid saying that "Cindy
and Susan are such good girls.
So sweet, so nice.
You could really learn
something from them.
They're not like you,
always working, working.
No time to meet anyone.
Wasting your beautiful years."
And then Ingrid's
response to that
is, "Well Cindy
and Susan probably
were both sweeter
and nicer than I was,
but you didn't make partner at
one of the most powerful firms
in the country by
being sweet and nice."
Can anyone climb
the corporate ladder
and still be sweet and
nice without wasting
their beautiful years?
HELEN WAN: No one has
ever asked that question
posed in quite that way before.
Although I do get asked a lot
in a lot of audiences of women
lawyers, for example,
we talk a lot about
is it possible to become
partner or be viewed
as a real rainmaking partner
without coming across
as this very aggressive
and frankly, quote,
"unfeminine" type.
I actually got
asked that question.
Can one remain a feminine type
person while achieving success?
And I think the answer
is hopefully yes.
Because first of all, I
think that if somebody is not
being authentic to
their own personality,
I actually don't
think that they're
going to be able to pull
that off forever and achieve
and maintain a level
of corporate success.
Because I think people can see
through the bullshit and go,
if you are natural
personality is not
that sort of hard driving,
aggressive, bad cop person,
I think that's not going
to ultimately be believed.
And so just as a matter
of personal survival,
I think you do have to cultivate
a workplace presence that
is believable because it's true.
SUNNI YUEN: And does work-life
balance mean different things
in that very top
corporate echelon
for ambitions men versus women?
HELEN WAN: Oh absolutely.
I think it still does.
But companies and firms
are getting better.
For example, one other
thing that I have seen
discussed a lot at the
companies and firms
have invited me to come speak
are a lot of conversations
about a flex time track.
A really possible
way to make partner
while still having
flexible schedules.
Actually a lot of tech companies
are leading the charge here.
Are really showing a lot of
leadership in this context.
But even older
companies as well.
With older, perhaps, and
more old school management,
also are coming
around to this idea.
I've been speaking
at a lot of law firms
where they have
actually laid out now
for the first time written
policies, whereas before it was
all kind of nebulous and
through word of mouth.
No one really knew what
the firm's real policy
was about flex time.
Whether one could make partner
and still be flex time.
Now some firms are actually
willing to write it down,
a policy, and
actually distribute it
to all of their lawyers and say,
there is a path to partnership
if you're flex time,
and here it is.
SUNNI YUEN: So they're
starting the dialogue,
they're being
transparent about it.
HELEN WAN: Exactly.
SUNNI YUEN: It's been codified.
HELEN WAN: Yeah.
Now how many women have?
How many women and men
successfully do that?
That's a different conversation.
But at least there's a path
now that is written down
and objective criteria
that can be disseminated
so that at least
people can be talking
about the same set
of criteria at least.
SUNNI YUEN: And
so just going back
to the question of
tackling stereotypes
and promoting diversity.
Your book actually
tackles a perception
that Asian Americans are often
viewed as the model minority.
HELEN WAN: Yes.
SUNNI YUEN: There's a scene
where Ingrid loses her temper
because one of the
partners says something
about Asian Americans
having done all right
because by objective
economic measure
they are right up
there with whites.
And then Ingrid goes berserk.
As berserk as you can.
HELEN WAN: Reasonably berserk.
SUNNI YUEN: That should be a new
phrase that pays, by the way.
And she breaks what she
calls her own cardinal rule
of avoiding any
discussion about race.
HELEN WAN: In the
workplace, yeah.
SUNNI YUEN: When
is the right time
to actually have that
conversation without making
an issue out of it in a
way that is not productive?
HELEN WAN: Right.
This is an absolutely
crucial, crucial question.
I think that the answer
depends maddeningly,
as with so many
other things, it's
totally context and
circumstance specific.
And it also depends
very, very much
on your own level and
position within that company
at that time.
So actually, one
young woman who I
met at one of these
book events, she
came up to me to ask about a
situation that had recently
happened to her.
She is a young lawyer.
She was at a social
event with a partner--
a very powerful partner-- who
heads the department that she
hopes to eventually
be very successful in.
And he made a ching chong joke.
Yes, people are
still doing this.
I know.
And he made a ching
chong joke about somebody
who was a business person
on the other side of a deal
that they were all working on.
And predictably,
the other two, who
were mid-level associates, who
heard the joke, were horrified.
But they also themselves
are subordinate
to this particular partner.
They are mid-level associates.
And so what they did
was they turned to her
and at least wanted
to let her know
that they understood
that this was crazy.
So they would turn to her
and go, sorry, but not
say something too him.
And then later, after they
were out of that situation,
both separately came to
her and said, oh my God.
WTF?
I am so sorry.
SUNNI YUEN: Was that
too late, though?
Because they waited reactively.
HELEN WAN: Right.
So the moment had passed.
There was no teachable moment
for that particular partner.
But quite honestly,
just thinking about it
and trying to situate
myself in that situation,
if I were the summer associate
I certainly would not
have felt comfortable lecturing
him under those circumstances.
And I don't know
enough about how senior
or what the position within
the firm of those other two
more mid-level
attorneys-- I don't
know enough about
those two people
to know whether there
could've been an opportunity
to raise the point or not.
I do think in general
those moments tend to pass
and a lot of teachable
moments are wasted,
or they're not
taken advantage of.
Which actually, it's sort of
a chicken and the egg problem,
right?
So the sooner we can have
more sensitized people
in more senior positions who are
on equal professional footing
with this particular
person, only then are you
going to have people who feel
fully comfortable saying, Bob,
seriously?
And until that
day comes, I think
there will be a lot of moments
like that lost into the ether.
And I also am very, very
sensitive to the fact
that I don't think
that we should
have unrealistic
expectations about what
people can feel
comfortable doing.
Most people are not
going to feel comfortable
challenging their boss, the
head of the department who
does their performance review.
SUNNI YUEN: Or a client.
HELEN WAN: Yeah, or a client.
You're not going to
lecture them on race.
You're just not.
And that's why I think that
the more there are people
who are on an equal
professional footing,
I think that these kinds
of unfortunate moments
will happen with less
and less and less
frequency in the future.
SUNNI YUEN: So how do you negate
the perception that sometimes
the idea is that
someone advances because
of a meritocracy?
They are darn good
at what they do.
They deserve to be promoted.
But then you also, because of
certain diversity initiatives,
there might be some
kind of perception
there is a quota-based system.
And I think in your book there's
an insinuation that Ingrid only
landed her role in a massive
transaction, massive deal,
because the vendor required
a certain representation
from a diverse associate.
How do you counter that,
and do quotas work?
HELEN WAN: Well
actually-- it comes from,
I think, people having their
hearts in the right place
and wanting to give more
business to, and more business
attribution credit to, more
people of color and women.
But I think you have to be
incredibly, incredibly careful
about the way these
so-called vendor
requirements, or minority
vendor requirements, in RFPs
get played out.
I think there's really a right
way and a wrong way to do it.
I think that the ways
in which it can actually
help move the needle positively
are when it's not just, hey
yeah, yeah, yeah, can you
bring some brown people
to the beauty pageant?
When we're shopping
for outside counsel.
I have seen that.
SUNNI YUEN: Was that
from personal experience?
HELEN WAN: I have
a lot of friends
who are lawyers and who are
now partners at their law firms
who have told me that they have
seen right ways and wrong ways
to do this at firms.
Where the client will
say, yeah please,
we would like to see
a female partner,
or we would like to see a
diverse attorney at the beauty
pageant.
And then so the firm does.
And the client clearly just
never follows up on it.
Never is like, you
know, I would like
to know out of those people
you brought to the beauty
pageant, who was actually
working on my matter?
How many hours did those people
actually bill on my matter?
And I want to know who
are the substantive deal
team leads working this
particular project.
And of course when the
client doesn't follow up,
the message that is then
sent to the law firm
is, well they don't
really care and they're
doing this as a check box.
However, I also know
of other companies
who are doing it in a
much more meaningful way.
Where yes, they
have messaged it is
important to us, Client X
corporation, for you guys
to have a diverse team
working on this matter.
And not only that, we intend to
develop personal relationships
with those attorneys
on your team who
are going to be
working on this matter.
I even have heard of companies
that are doing really
great, very creative programs
such as seconding attorneys
in-house so that the client
really does have an opportunity
to develop a personal
relationship with these kind
of up-and-coming lawyers.
And that definitely does lead
to real progress I have seen.
SUNNI YUEN: And just going
to, again, narrow a lens
to your character's
journey in your book,
Ingrid gets stymied in
their partner track quest.
And then at the end
when she's stymied
by institutional
obstacles, she's
tried the conventional path.
She's tried to beat the system
by playing along the rules
by passing, by blending.
And then at the end of it
she comes out and just says,
I'm going to just pretty much
charge my own path forward.
Do you think that's common
for smart, independent women
to first try the conventional
path before deciding
to make the leap into
becoming a solo entrepreneur?
HELEN WAN: Yes, absolutely.
And I think it's particularly
common for Asian American men
and women to do that.
SUNNI YUEN: Why is that?
HELEN WAN: I just think
that there are a lot of--
and obviously it was
very important to me
in writing this book-- I wrote
this book because when I landed
as a 25-year-old, first
job out of law school.
Not only was it my first
job out of law school,
it was my first job period.
Because I had gone straight
through from high school
to college to law school.
Landed in the M&A department at
this large national law firm.
It's truly, not counting
things like summer internships,
actually was my
first job, crazily.
If you think about that.
And when I got there I realized
that all of those skill
sets that had served me so well
up until that point in my life,
namely knowing how
to be good at school,
knowing how to take
tests well, knowing
how to make good grades,
just studying hard,
knowing how to do that.
Were sort of out the window.
They were kind of irrelevant
in the corporate game.
I mean obviously hard
work, yes it is important.
You have to have the
goods, after all.
But everybody does
at that point.
You are starting over
with a fresh slate.
Everyone there was
a good student.
Everyone there aced the LSAT.
Everyone there graduated from
the same five law schools
and landed in Manhattan.
So being a good student no
longer distinguishes you.
What does distinguish
you, however,
is being really, really fluent
in the language of the firm.
Being really great at
integrating yourself
in the social
fabric of the firm.
I soon realized that
contrary to everything
that my-- at least in my own
Chinese American family--
contrary to what a lot
of Chinese American first
generation immigrant
kids are told, I think,
it is actually
far more important
to show up at the Fridays
at five cocktail hour
rather than spend that hour
holed up in your office
with the door closed
billing, billing, billing.
Totally invisible and no
one knows you're in there.
Those were the cultural
messages of hey,
how to be successful
in your first job,
that I actually had to relearn.
Because all of those things that
a lot of Asian American kids
are told, for example,
self promotion is bad.
It's a bad word.
Don't self-promote.
You have to be humble.
You have to be modest.
You have to keep your head down.
Don't stick out.
Don't rock the boat.
Just go along and
it's a meritocracy,
so hard work will be rewarded.
And hard work matters,
but by the time
you reach the Parsons
Valentines of the world,
everyone there is
good at what they do.
So you need to master
those soft skills
that they can't teach you in
business school or law school.
I wasn't seeing any smart
contemporary stories
being written about
that experience
from the point of view
of a young person trying
to make his or her way
in corporate America.
So that's why I wrote the book.
SUNNI YUEN: Great book.
We should check it out.
We have a few minutes
open for questions,
if anyone in the
audience has any.
Make sure you go to the
mic so we can capture it.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I
have a question.
I'm not really sure
the answer, which
is why I'm asking the question.
Or how to find out
the answer to this.
But would you say that is
harder to overcome adversity
in corporate America if you
come from a background of being
poor, like not
having lots of means,
or coming from a class of
people that was traditionally
discriminated against,
whether or not you have means?
Thank you.
HELEN WAN: Interesting question.
I actually don't know
that one has a harder
road then the other.
One thing that it
was important to me
to do with the
characters in the story
is to portray that actually
everyone-- Ingrid mistakenly
assumes that everyone
else finds the firm
experience easier than she does.
And that is a wrong--
that's not true.
So without giving
anything away, there
is one character for whom class
politics becomes very, very
important.
And I don't think that you can
make the statement that one
necessarily outweighs the other.
But I do think that
it was important to me
to be writing about
someone who occupies
this sort of double
outsider status.
Ingrid is not only woman,
but also a minority.
And I do think that
when one occupies
that kind of double
outsider status
it certainly compounds things.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds
like personally the story
is only vaguely
autobiographical,
but how closely how closely do
the protagonist's experiences
at the law firm mirror
what you experienced there?
HELEN WAN: Oh, well
I definitely tried
to make the anecdotes
and the experiences that
happened to all of
the young lawyers
at the firm as
realistic as possible.
I certainly did draw from
my own personal experiences
and the experiences
of-- I'm very
lucky to have a close
knit group of friends
who were very
forthcoming in sharing
their own personal real
life experiences in whatever
corporate setting they work in.
Whether it's media or the
financial sector or tech.
They're not all
lawyers, but they do all
work in corporate America.
And when we get together
and just in trusted company
and share stories,
it was amazing to me
how remarkably similar
a lot of our experiences
in corporate America
were and are.
And so that was when some
of us would jokingly say,
someone should write
these all down.
Someone should write a book.
And so I did start
writing them down.
So yes.
The scenes that take place
in the book, while fiction,
I tried very hard to make
them as realistic as possible.
And based on the kinds of things
that can and do still happen.
AUDIENCE: Another question.
So it sounds like writing
this but was something
of a calling based on your
experiences with life.
But having written one book
of fiction, was it fun?
Would you do it again?
HELEN WAN: Oh yes, absolutely.
Yes.
This has been a tremendous,
tremendous experience.
I still kind of
feel like I'm having
a great dream from which
I will wake up any moment.
Getting a text from a
friend being like, did
you know that your book is
reviewed in today's Wall Street
Journal was kind of like, what?
It has been just such a
tremendous learning experience.
I really like actually speaking
to student audiences the best.
I mean, no offense to Google.
But it's so gratifying when
you meet a young reader who
comes up, gets his or her
book signed, and tells you,
I wish I had been
able to read this book
when I was 17 at my boarding
school in Massachusetts,
because I would've
felt much less alone.
That just totally
makes my whole day
and just makes me feel like wow.
OK.
The 12 years that I have
spent writing this book
may have been worth it,
if one person can tell me
that my book helped make them
feel a little less alone.
To a first-time novelist
there's no better compliment.
So yes, absolutely.
I would write a book again.
And I am working on book two.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
coming to chat with us.
HELEN WAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I though your
description of the law firm
diversity initiatives
was really funny.
And before I came here, I was
an M&A associate at a big firm.
And I remember those
sort of very ham-handed,
but in my opinion
well-intentioned--
HELEN WAN: I think
well-intentioned too.
AUDIENCE: At tempts
at diversity.
Or promoting
diversity or some sort
of understanding
among colleagues.
So I was curious
as to your thoughts
on to what extent you can
ever do a diversity initiative
in a way that doesn't
seem like very silly
or doesn't end with
margaritas on Cinco de Mayo?
HELEN WAN: I think that
yes, absolutely there
are-- as we were just came
out with the minority vendor
requirements, there
are great ways
and wrong ways to do diversity
efforts at law firms as well.
Or companies, for that matter.
And it's been interesting
that-- it is a novel,
and this fictitious
firm is quite clearly
doing it the wrong way.
But only because they're doing
it not for the right reasons.
The motivations are not genuine.
But I am seeing a lot of law
firms where, as you said,
it is incredibly
well-intentioned.
They are doing, like a
lot of the initiatives
that I just described,
about trainings
on what are the tools that you
can use to actually identify
for yourself the
right mentor, sponsor.
Then how do you go and
organically cultivate
these relationships?
I've seen
culturally-specific trainings
geared at young
associates at law firms
to, for lack of a
better term, cultivate
what is your leadership style?
Cultivate an executive presence.
Cultivate and develop your
personal brand/ and then make
sure you are projecting your
personal brand throughout
the company or firm.
For example, if you are
young associate that
works in a satellite
office, how do you
make sure that your own
personal brand is not only
known to people who can help you
professionally at headquarters,
but throughout the rest of
the locations of the company?
I'm seeing a lot
of firms talking
about real hands-on trainings,
which obviously are far more
useful than drinks
on Cinco de Mayo.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
But those things are all sort
of facially diversity-neutral,
right?
Which I like.
It's like you, Asian
American associate,
have as much need for a
mentor who understands you
as this associate over here.
Or maybe more so.
You could argue
different things.
But it isn't say Lunar Gala
dumplings sort of event.
I was curious to
what extent do you
think even cognizing
of the concept,
or discussing the
concept of diversity
puts people in a
different frame of mind?
HELEN WAN: You mean to what
extent are you kind of,
unfortunately, pigeonholing
when you even talk about,
hey here's a--
AUDIENCE: Right.
When you walk into a
room and say, hey guys
we're going to
celebrate diversity,
or we're going to
make sure that we
have a diverse
set of associates,
that you've already
sort of separated
some people from others.
HELEN WAN: Well
actually, I was just
talking about this
with someone who
works in the-- she is a
diversity and inclusion
officer at a law firm.
And she said it
is for that reason
that now law firms are
incredibly, incredibly
careful to when they have a
culturally specific program
like that, like that
you're talking about,
the audience has to be
self-selecting, obviously.
You can't just take the
roster of attorneys,
pick out all of the Chens
and Chos and Wongs and Wangs
and invite them
to a, hey, here's
a program on to be
more aggressive.
One law firm actually recently
got into a bit of trouble
for disseminating a memo
to female-- you probably
know what I'm talking
about about-- attorneys
on certain tips that
were not taken kindly
by lot of the attorneys.
So I think that a
lot of law firms
have done very, very
wise to the fact
that many people
may actually want
some of these culturally
specific trainings,
but the audience
has to self-select.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One more question.
Earlier when you were
answering a question
you mentioned vendors saying,
send these people to the beauty
pageant, and I was confused.
I've never heard that term.
Is that a [INAUDIBLE]?
HELEN WAN: Sorry.
That's a phrase
that pays for us.
Beauty pageant is when a
client, let's say Google,
needs to hire outside
counsel for a particularly
large transaction
or other matter
and they are
interviewing law firms.
And each law firm has to come
in an interview for the job,
for the gig.
We call those beauty pageants.
SUNNI YUEN: It's
pitching, basically.
HELEN WAN: It's
a business pitch.
And you would be
surprised-- maybe you
wouldn't be surprised-- how
many times a senior woman
or a senior African American,
Latina, or Asian American
partner gets sent to
that business pitch
but yet, curiously,
doesn't work on the matter.
SUNNI YUEN: All right.
Great.
So thank you, Helen,
for coming in.
HELEN WAN: Thank you so much.
I had so much fun being here.